y su padre ramesh llegaron a acatar con
la esperanza de construir una vida mejor
solo el hijo de este hogar en Duelo
regreso de vuelta a esta pequeña casa al
sur de India la familia cayó 10 uno de
los tantos hogares que acusan al Estado
anfitrión de la Copa del Mundo de las
malas condiciones laborales y los abusos
durante la construcción de los estadios
de fútbol
pensé que tendríamos días Buenos pensé
que la compañía era buena pero Dios
maldijo nuestra vida mi esposo murió
cuando estaba vivo enviaba dinero empecé
a construir esta casa y recién estábamos
acabando de edificar las vigas cuando
murió
katara ha enfrentado duras críticas por
las muertes lesiones e incumplimiento de
salarios a trabajadores extranjeros el
90% de las 2,8 millones de personas que
viven en el país árabe son migrantes la
mayoría provienen de países como India
bangladesh nepal Kenia o filipinas
6.500 trabajadores fallecidos fue la
cifra que sacudió al mundo un dato
suministrado por el diario Guardian que
luego las autoridades de doja
contrastaron con tan solo 34 muertes de
forma oficial de las cuales sólo tres
adjudicaron a un accidente laboral los
funcionarios cataríes acusan a los
críticos de ignorar las reformas y
aplicar un doble rasero a la primera
nación árabe en albergar el Torneo Pues
aseguran el país del Golfo ha
introducido importantes reformas para
mejorar la seguridad de los trabajadores
y castigar a los empleadores que violen
las reglas sin embargo tiempo después un
alto funcionario catarí reconoció la
muerte de muchos más
la estimaciones de alrededor de 400
entre 400 y 500 no tengo el número
Exacto eso es algo que está sucediendo
una muerte ya es mucho así de simple sin
embargo creo que cada año mejoran las
normas de salud y seguridad en las obras
como la familia calladitos todavía
esperan los restos de sus familiares y
la respuesta de un país se construyó la
gloria de sus estadios bajo la tragedia
de miles de migrantes